sí muy buenas tardes para todos ustedes
pues la audiencia comenzó hace unos
pocos minutos
durante esta semana la idea es escuchar
a estos 14 sospechosos
conocer es un interrogatorio sobre su
personalidad saber quiénes son estas
personas preguntarles sobre su niñez
sobre su pasado sobre si han tenido
antecedentes penales o no uno de los
puntos que generan un poquito de
discordia es que el presidente de este
tribunal decidió que no se les va a
hacer ningún tipo de preguntas de
carácter religioso sobre en qué momento
decidieron pues ya sea convertirse al
islám o en qué momento decidieron ir a
siria a combatir en las filas del estado
islámico para aquellos que lo hicieron
está generado un poquito de controversia
sin embargo pues a una parte de los
abogados de la defensa consideran que es
mejor así que de todas maneras pues hay
que respetar la decisión del presidente
de este tribunal pero para muchos
también esta es una etapa importante y
es un momento crucial porque permite
saber quiénes son estas personas y
también saber qué fue aquello que las
motivó a formar parte de quienes se
realizaron estos atentados en noviembre
de 2000 15 en parís otra de las
preguntas que muchos se hacen bueno esta
audiencia que comenzará por el
interrogatorio es a la abdeslam que es
el principal de los acusados es el único
sobre quien pesan cargos por crímenes
terroristas y es el único sobreviviente
de ese comando que realizó los atentados
en el 2015 y la pregunta es saber si él
va a hablar porque él por lo general
pues es alguien que es muy escaso muy
poco elocuente entonces esa es una de
las preguntas y cuando ha hablado a esta
corte pues en realidad ha generado
bastante impacto por las palabras
fuertes que ha tenido en algún momento a
lo largo de estas cinco semanas él pudo
hablar a lo largo estas cinco semanas
que se escucharon los testimonios pues
de las vidas de los sobrevivientes y de
los familiares de las víctimas él dijo
que el blanco no eran estas personas al
blanco era simplemente francia y pues
que ahí no hacían distinción de si eran
hombres mujeres
franceses o de cualquiera nacionalidad y
había dicho de todas maneras que había
que mantener la puerta abierta ante el
diálogo y pues por último pues vamos a
ver si durante estos días todos estos
testimonios desgarradores que se
escucharon a lo largo de semanas
hicieron media o no en estos acusados